l'autoroute a10 près des atlantes le
ballet des camions commencent dans
quelques heures caméra techniciens et
acteurs seront là un couteau dans le
coeur et le second long métrage de yann
gonzales son thriller se passe durant
l'été 1979
vanessa paradis campe le rôle à dan une
productrice de films pornographiques
gays rongé par l'alcool et qui tentent
de refaire surface après s'être fait
plaquer par son grand amour
sa loge dans une heure à peu près ça va
être ce que j'appelle le débarquement ou
un fourmillement de personnes et de
matériels vont arriver on va être une
cinquantaine de personnes la décoration
à intervenir en amont pour rendre le
lieu crédible et lisible à l'image comme
décor années 70 et ensuite on commencera
à tourner dès que la nuit va tomber
toute la nuit en présence des pompiers
qui vont bien nous mouiller le sol pour
avoir un raccord avec un décor qu'on a
tourné ailleurs autre rôle dans ce
thriller tourné en partie en indre et
loire
romane bohringer et nicolas maury que
vous avez découvert dans la série de
france 2 10%
la venue de ces stars du cinéma français
est presque passée inaperçue car toutes
les scènes étaient tournées de nuit
on est parfois dans le milieu très
urbain et dans les autres parfois dans
un milieu très rurale donc on a fait
déjà des séquences par exemple d'un
cimetière ou d'une forêt au nord de
tours assez réelle et la semaine
dernière on était à joué-lès-tours dans
un appartement hlm typiquement années
soixante dix avec les huisseries
d'époque etc
demain vanessa paradis et les autres
acteurs se rendront à châteauroux pour
une scène tournée dans un wagon